the book is titled chameleon what does
that mean to you yeah I mean being a
chameleon just means being able to adapt
being able to adapt to any situation I'm
not the same person I am with my wife as
I am with you I'm not the same person I
am with my wife as I am with my kids I'm
not the same person I am with my kids as
I am with my friends like or you know I
am with a boss who I like or a boy so I
don't like or visit my like we're always
chameleons all the time it's just we're
not conscious of it
all right guys bang bang I've got Remy
here with me Remy you've got this really
interesting background where you were a
Navy SEAL uh you've gone on to uh have
movies and books and TV shows and kind
of this whole world of media and
entertainment
when you think about your life are you
an Entertainer whether you're in uniform
or you're now professionally working in
the media and entertainment business
like there is this element in the
military of you're constantly
entertaining those that are next to you
those you're interacting with like is
this just something that is a thread
throughout your whole life of
entertaining other people
I don't you know I mean maybe when I was
a kid for sure you know and you know
when I watching movies and trying to
mimic movies and and especially like
Martin Lawrence and Eddie Murphy and
those guys trying to make my friends
laugh I would say in my younger years ah
when I got into the military I don't I
don't think so I think for me it was
just all about getting the job done in
all business in fact it was towards the
end of my career that I decided that I
wanted to go into business Consulting
full-time and so I got my bachelor's and
then uh in my last two years in the
teens and then right after I got out I
was in grad school getting my master's
and again my plan was I was working with
ypos and other guys essentially taking
Special Operations principles that
translates into business and so that's
what I was going to do uh and then
Hollywood came knocking and then I kind
of found my way in Hollywood a few
months later so it definitely wasn't
something that was planned it was uh
something that kind of just came out of
nowhere when you say that Hollywood came
knocking what do you mean
uh I was um in grad school and I got out
in January 2016. I was probably my
second and third semester of grad school
gave my Master's in organizational
strategy and uh that was January and
then fast forward to May of 2016. I was
in my office this very office right here
writing papers and I got a phone call
from a woman who worked with Michael Bay
and she said hey bae's looking for a
former Navy SEAL with your background to
consult and work on Transformers the
last night with you know and and she
said hey can you send me some pictures
first she asked me if I was available I
said yeah I'm not doing anything but
writing papers I can get up to LA
tomorrow and then she uh uh she asked me
to send to send her some pictures and I
did and the next day I was on set so
that's essentially what I mean I wasn't
out here chasing it somebody just
essentially knocked on my proverbial
door and gave me a call and then the
next said I'm day I'm working on set and
one day turned into three weeks three
weeks turned into six months and it was
in that period that I really began to to
realize that I love story selling I love
being able to utilize my experiences my
background to help formulate and create
uh and share a story because story has
such a a huge impact on um not just
people in America but people culturally
and internationally all around the world
one of the things that every single
person I know uh in the military or
every successful Business Leaders
there's a sense of urgency right and
there's also a sense of being open to
opportunity and being able to kind of
seize the moment so obviously if you get
a phone call and the next day you're on
set that's like the epitome of doing
this is that something that you've had
your entire life did you learn in the
military why are you uniquely able to do
that for someone who may be like yeah
you know I'm interested but uh I'll get
back to you in two weeks and kind of you
know we'll go from there yeah I think it
comes from the teams being in the SEAL
Teams you know we're at the acronym seal
stands for sea air and land and so we
have it's kind of beaten to us in Seal
training to this uh ability to be
flexible this ability to be a jack of
all trades and be open and and we also
train to contingencies uh so once you
get through SEAL training and then you
um get to your civil platoon and you do
your work up a lot of your workup
whether it's CQC land War for your
diving it's always not just training for
the mission but it's also training for
the what is right the curveballs that
come your way and so I would say that
that was essentially ingrained in me
through the community uh and so when I
got out and this kind of curveball came
my way it was just like all right let's
let's jump into it you know for me it
was like I know that that's what that
wasn't my plan and that's not what I
wanted to do but it's a part of my
nature as a frog man to uh jump into
crazy things and and be open to the
opportunity and then once you get the
opportunity or you get the curveball you
do it with Excellence so you operate
within that that space with excellent so
um I would say wholeheartedly it didn't
come from my upbring and it came more so
from my time in in the teams that makes
uh that makes a lot of sense you were
born in Nigeria and then ended up in the
Bronx in New York talk a little bit
about kind of your early childhood and
and you know some of the things that
happened there but also some of the
lessons maybe took away from it yeah so
my dad he was a uh very successful
entrepreneur businessman you name it he
did it he was one of the first black men
on the board of the World Trade Center
in New York City did a lot of business
in New York City and he was also one of
the uh the uh the first black man on the
board of the British financial planning
Council in Great Britain and he had Mass
great wealth in the west and then he
returned to Nigeria he's actually born
in Nigeria he was the firstborn son to
my grandfather Chief uh at elake uh he
kept on having he had nine wives kept on
having daughters my dad was the
firstborn son so he inherited the title
of Chief and it kind of became the heir
to the euroba Thrones so to speak and so
after his Time in the West again he went
back to Nigeria and uh his plan was to
essentially develop a African Wall
Street
um uh uh and it was the title of the
project was Lagoon City he bought a
massive plot of land in Marico for eight
million pounds this is in the 70s there
was a military uh coup shortly after and
that and got taken by the government he
went to court for a number of years for
the Nigerian government and then finally
they came back and said okay we won't
give you Marico
um but what do you want for compensation
and so he asked for Lagoon and they
laughed at him because they said what
are you going to do with a lagoon and he
hired Dutch engineers and dredged the
foreshore and created one under first
man-made Islands uh in the world um
which is now known as Banana Island but
it was known as Lagoon City I was born
around that time so
um I was born into riches and wealth and
we traveled the world and and my dad
hosted parties with dignitaries and and
one of his best friends was um was the
uh designer architect of the World Trade
Center a Japanese guy uh and uh uh you
know my dad was just super influential
and uh because of his success you know
we lived a great life but fast forward
to 1987 the Nigerian state government um
the Nigerian government is inherently
corrupt all around but the state
government came in and said that the
federal government was never supposed to
give my dad the lagoonist compensation
because the foreshore belongs to the um
state government and they conveniently
waited until the land had formed and
construction had had started on the
island as far as buildings uh to do that
so um which I mean they all knew what
was going on for the years that it took
to took taterness Lagoon into an island
but they conveniently weighed in my dad
went to go fight him in court died
mysteriously three weeks later and we
went from very rich to very poor and uh
my mom then being American brought my
brother and I back to the States and we
grew up in a bronx
um it was a very rough environment
um crackheads drug dealers crime
um I remember seeing the mafia guys
going to the corner stores with their
big collars and shake down the store
owners for their taxes uh it was a very
very rough environment and uh As I Grew
Older
8 9 10 I began to become more conscious
of my surroundings because my mom she
did a fantastic job of masking the
reality of what had happened uh and
keeping us in this bubble for as long as
she could but as I got older and I got a
chance to venture off that's when I
began to to notice things more so and
that's when I also began to try to find
a father in the streets in hip-hop
culture rap culture all of these things
that were prevalent in the late 80s and
early 90s and that led me down a really
bad path started out stealing for my mom
and then that progressed to stealing
from stores that progressed distilling
from jobs that progressed to selling
drugs and then that Progressive running
high level scams and by the time I was
19 I had built a massive illegal
Enterprise where I was bringing in 10 10
like tens of thousands of dollars a week
running a cell phone scam because cell
phones have just become prominent so
that was a and a quick nutshell that was
my uh Nigeria the Bronx upbringing well
let me I want to unpack some of this
because it's this uh fascinating story
right where basically you get the highs
and the lows in a very short period a
time kind of as a kid when you're very
formidable when your dad was going
through this on one hand there's this
you know uh probably proud of your
father to go and fight back against the
government and say hey no look you took
my land I need to be compensated for it
at the same time as you described
there's this mysterious death and I
don't know how much kind of you guys
know or or didn't really spend the time
to try to figure it out how do you think
back around you know a private citizen
private property rights and then
government and kind of their ability to
do things like that whether it's in
Nigeria or in any country really around
the world like what are some of the
lessons maybe that you took away from
that as a kid uh you know I was too
young to really take away any lessons I
was five years old at the time
um but I would say now as an adult
looking back in retrospect is you know
just the the greatness of America you
know our ability to to have those rights
and not have to worry about buying a
house and then the government come along
one day and saying that that house
doesn't belong to you so you know now it
belongs to us
um and uh and and just happen to having
the freedoms that we have here so I look
at it more so uh in retrospect and and
and you know I've been able to uh you
know build wealth uh you know starting
from the bottom but
um to where I am at now and I've been
able to kind of build wealth because of
the freedoms and and the laws and the
rules that we have in place which do not
exist in Nigeria I get Nigerians on a
daily basis that email me or message me
on social media and they say please can
you please bring me to America
or can you please come back to Nigerian
and and help fight the government and
run for power I get a lot of people to
ask me to come back and running you know
get into politics and uh I don't have a
desire to because I know how corrupt the
system is it's going to take a complete
dismantling of uh the Nigerian political
system in order for it to uh to to be
what it can be and Nigeria has the
potential to be great because it's a
very it's a very rich and resource
country when you look at natural the
natural gas that they that can be
produced oil
um cocoa gold and all these other
minerals I mean look at what China's
doing there and they're going into not
just Nigeria but other parts of of
Africa and they're just buying up all of
this real estate in order to be able to
mine and pull these resources out
because because of the resources that
are in in Nigeria and in in these other
parts of Africa and so Nigeria does have
the potential to be a very wealthy and
successful uh country where majority of
the people are thriving but the
corruption is just so out of control so
um I know that was a long answer but in
short that that it's more of a
retrospective uh look than than uh
essentially uh having an assessment when
I was that early of an age yeah when
um I went to Nigeria and uh stayed in
Lagos and not on Victoria Island but
actually like in Lagos near computer
Village and I told the story before on
the podcast uh the energy in Nigeria is
just off the charts right just walking
around for whatever reason it's just you
just know it's a special place and and
uh the way that people interact with you
and with each other and stuff is uh
something that you wish you could just
bottle up and you're like man this place
has so much potential and you look at
you the population size and how fast
it's growing and the estimates that you
know there's going to be more Nigerians
than Americans by 2050 and just all
these different uh components like this
place could be amazing but when you talk
to Nigerians the government and the
corruption is one of the things they
point to and they say yeah we just got
this like governor on the speed we can
go until we kind of fix that problem no
100 and the crazy thing is like in the
inner city of New York City there's
other inner cities when people are in
poverty uh young people specifically uh
what do they look to to get out of
poverty for the most part at least go
speaking from my experience it's like
sports uh music or you know selling
drugs right because that's what they're
exposed to in Nigeria
um every kid from the time they're young
they're taught whatever you do work your
way into politics because if you can get
into politics then that's the way you
can get rich you have people who become
Governors or senators in Nigeria with
having no wealth they're just great
talkers and great manipulators and then
they come out of office billionaires not
millionaires
billionaires and so that's the goal for
a lot of people in Nigeria is to get
into politics because they know hey once
I get to the as a matter of fact I
remember falling in Nigeria in 2018 to
finish writing my to finish um writing
my book and uh as soon as I got off the
plane
um the Customs officer said what gift do
you have for me like do you have a gift
for me you know in order to get through
customs you have to give me a gift and
then you and then we got pulled over and
and that police said how much money are
you going to give me in order to get
through so it's so systemic the
corruption and and it's a whatever
position somebody's at in Nigeria from
the smallest position as a customs
officer they're gonna shake you down and
if they can shake you down for five
dollars as a custom officer just imagine
what the governors and the Senators and
the ministry of oil I mean it was a
story that came out I want to say around
2014 2015 where the ministry of oil you
know they found and again I might be
butchering the story but the spirit of
it is she was cutting side deals uh with
other countries and shipping oil
to these other countries so the so the
of a shipment of oil costs I don't know
15 billion dollars I'm just throwing out
a random number to give this example she
would sell it for 5 billion pocket the 5
billion the ship would disappear the
other country would get the oil and now
she's a billionaire and then when she
got caught she jumped on a plane to
London and uh when the Nigerian
government was like you got to come back
and face charges because you got caught
she's like I have cancer so I need to
stay here and seek treatment so you know
that that's what everybody that's not
everybody but that's what a good number
of Nigerians you know do in politics is
they just steal and they their kids are
raised to hey don't try to become a
basketball player or a doctor or lawyer
try to become a politician because
that's how you're going to get rich and
be able to get your family out of the
poverty that they're in you know it's
which is sad there's some families in
America who have the same strategy of
just getting oh 100
100 oh yeah and they have people who
just go into politics for that reason
because they've they've but I would just
say it's
widespread in Nigeria than it is and
it's more overt it's more widespread and
it's more over in Nigeria here it's more
clandestine because of our rules and the
laws and our rights but hey it's it's
it's it's disgusting uh wherever it
happens you know completely agree um
talk about your mom obviously being uh
kind of in a situation where uh your
father had generated great wealth you
went to Nigeria uh you and your siblings
were born there
um and then all of a sudden you kind of
return back from wealth to you know a
degree of poverty like how did she
handle that navigate it and was the move
back to New York's more of like running
to the uh familiar or was it running
away from the situation like how as you
grew up did you kind of uh talk to her
or what did you learn
yeah my mom was just she's just a beast
what I think she there was a trigger for
her after my dad died she contacted a
cousin that she had grown up with and uh
he was he was well to do a lawyer in New
York City and uh she reached out to him
and said I don't have a nickel to my
name uh I'm I'm coming back to New York
while I'm back in New York I can't
remember the time period uh this was
shortly after my dad died though and uh
can you just loan me some money until
like I I can get myself together and uh
uh get my kids squared away with put
food and clothing and schooling and all
that and about five minutes later his
wife called her back and said uh how
dare you call my husband and ask him for
money
um you know uh don't you ever do that
again and hung up the phone on my mom
and it was in that moment that the
switch went off my mom's head the birds
had Bones the boats have been burned no
one's coming to my rescue I need to
figure this out on my own and so my mom
you know she worked multiple jobs she
started out as a teacher in the South
Bronx but then she would also work at
museums and art galleries and Midtown
Manhattan to be able to expose my
brother and I to the arts for free so
that we can get a secondary education
through her teaching
um she started creative writing business
called First Impressions writing
services where she would again teach
work at the Museum and then people would
give her Turnpike she was chat GTP
before there was a chat GTP uh uh and
she would write term papers and resumes
and and and and and you know all and and
letters for people and get paid so she
would just work grind hard I mean uh she
would wake up in the morning uh before
my brother and I would wake up run that
we had 17 flights in our 17 floors in
our building she will run up that and
down the stairs for a workout because
she couldn't afford a gym come back
downstairs wake my brother and I up get
us ready for for school send us to
school then she would go work come back
from work uh help us with our homework
work another job feed us work another
job and then put us down to sleep and
then work some more so that was
something that I saw as a kid and I
would ask my mom why are you working or
I didn't understand it as a young kid
and then I now looking back it's because
she was trying to provide for two boys
and again she was trying to create an
environment for us that where we could
Thrive and become something and I
remember asking her in my my early 20s I
said mom why didn't you ever remarry and
she said because I didn't want to bring
any confusion into the house and I knew
that my main focus needed to be you guys
because as you and your brother were
successful then everything would be all
right and then I would be all right in
the long run and so
and so that's why she worked as hard as
she did and it paid off you know it all
eventually paid off and but more
importantly it gave me the template for
how to work it showed me the importance
of of putting in the work and going the
extra while my mom would always tell me
my brother whatever you do do it right
the first time
um she would make my brother and I read
New York Times articles and books and
then write reports uh on those books and
articles and if the reports weren't near
perfect which for me as a anyone that my
brother he's an engineer so he would do
better than me she would make us pick
another article book and start all over
again from scratch right and what she
was trying to instill in US was the
importance of doing everything right the
first time and doing everything with
excellence and she was also trying to
um instill into us the importance of
being able to write because from her
perspective if you knew how she figured
if my brother brother and I could knew
how to articulate ourselves in a
literary form that we would never be
without a job we would always be able to
work and so she was just forward
thinking in that sense and so I say all
that to say you know she set the
template for me and I I know about an
unequivocal doubt that I would not have
made it through the military made it in
the seal train and made it through SEAL
training be who I am and where I'm at
today without that constant reminder and
that that that that example as a young
boy of hard work and the importance of
hard work
so how do you go from doing book reports
and article reports to run in cell phone
scams like that like that's that's a
jump right and to some degree it's like
inside the house almost like you're
you're one person and then it seems like
outside the house you're a different
person right like talk talk through a
little bit as to how that uh happens and
how do you balance that in your head now
yeah I was a chameleon you know just
like the the title of my book right
there chameleon I learned how to be a
chameleon at an early age I learned okay
this is how I need to be with my mom uh
to keep her off my back and and figuring
out what I'm doing and this is who I
need and how I need to be when I'm out
in the streets doing what I'm doing I
needed to do pre you know not like like
exceedingly Above and Beyond in school
but I needed to meet the standard in
school and as long as I'm meeting the
standard in school and I'm graduating to
the next grade on time she's going to
stay off my back so and that will allow
me to do what I do so I would just so
the easiest answer to that was I was a
chameleon and uh and for me it was
especially the young age it was all
about making money and I think a big
part of that also was I had my dad's
entrepreneur DNA and mindset you know so
uh I didn't really want to work with
people if I say and that's why when I
did work for people you know I I stole I
figured out a way to create a business
out of the business that I was working
in if that makes sense and so um it all
boiled down to wanting to make money and
wanting to be affirmed you know I think
that that was also a big part of it you
know I believe that every boy needs a
father to affirm him and to to teach him
how to be a man if not he's going to
seek affirmation from other things
people and relationships Etc and that's
the same thing with every girl every
girl needs a father uh to teach her how
to be loved by a man in the T into a
father to affirm her so that she's not
seeking affirmation in relationships and
the wrong things and so in retrospect I
can say that the the main reason why I
got into the stuff that I got into was
because unconsciously I was seeking that
pat on the back from my dad that I never
got because my dad died you know I was
seeking for people to hey you're the man
uh you're doing great you're doing this
and so that's how I was a that's why I
was able to progress from doing things I
was doing and selling drugs and and
eventually you know running the high
level scams or the cell phone scams what
was the scam so uh there was a I won't
mention the whole company's name uh but
uh uh I uh was able to get a license
with a cell phone company uh we'll just
call it wct because that's what I I
named them in my Memoir transform but uh
I uh was working with this company
called wct and uh um I was able to get a
license to sell phones this one's cell
phones had just come out you know the
first phone was like the Nokia and it
had the snake game on it and then you
had the Motorola flip phones and all
that and everybody was work you know was
was enticed especially in New York City
by this and so
um um what I would do was I eventually
connected with a guy who I went to high
school with and his girlfriend worked at
a hospice
and so he would get me
um uh names date of births uh addresses
and Social Security uh number and then I
would activate
phones on so on one person's line of
credit I can activate up the three
phones
and uh the bill wouldn't come in for 30
days and then uh the person had 30 days
to pay the bill which they wanted uh so
then the phone was staying within 60
days and then in 90 days the phone would
turn off and so I found a niche a nation
with with drug dealers because they love
the phones because they had unlimited uh
cell phone calling because I was I was
doing Unlimited phone calls before
unlimited minutes before it existed uh
because they would have the phone for 90
days Unlimited phone calls and then uh
it would turn off and then I would get
them a new one so they weren't easy it
was hard for them to be tracing the
people whose information
um uh we were using were essentially
either on their way to on their deathbed
or or they had died in the process of me
activating the phone so nobody was was
uh was uh looking in on it and so
essentially that's that's kind of that
was the cell phone scam and I was
selling phones for between 300 and to
900 depending on the phones and then the
Motorola two-way Pages came out which
were like like they look like little
miniature laptops and they were there
was a gray one and a black one and so I
would sell those for about five to six
hundred dollars a pop and uh that's
essentially how I was I was making money
and then I started a record company I
keep this on my desk as a reminder
because this was our compilation album
and uh and I would essentially launder
the money through the record company uh
and my exit plan was to essentially you
know get enough compilations album
albums together and sell some numbers so
that we could track if we could show
proof of concept to record companies and
then sign a label deal because that's
what you know Jay-Z and and Damon Dash
did at the time they were selling drugs
they used drugs to essentially fund
their music business and then that's how
they that was an Exit Plan the music
business and and murdering and a lot of
these other guys so I was trying to
follow that template so that was uh that
was a cell phone scam and that's kind of
how it all worked together so you go
from that to 2002 I think it is you
enroll in the Navy and
what you mentioned earlier is your dad
was on the board the World Trade Center
he knew the designer uh or the uh you
know engineer an architect of uh the
World Trade Center yeah 911 drove the
decision to join the Navy or completely
unrelated now it was completely
unrelated
um um I had ended up getting involved in
a deal with a drug dealer that went bad
sold them another number of phones it
was supposed to stand stay on for 90
days they only stayed on for two weeks
um he he had already flipped the phone
so I so if I if I sold them 500 he
didn't turn sold the phone for a
thousand dollars so he owed a lot of
people money that and they were upset so
um after he threatened my life my mom's
life was threatened huge wake-up call
for me that's when I decided hey I'm not
doing this anymore uh and uh tried to
sell the record company that didn't work
itself out and then finally
um in 2002 that's when I kind of looked
at my life and I saw that my life had an
amounted to anything and I realized that
if I stay in the Bronx I'm gonna either
end up dead or in prison because there
were people who were doing the same
things that I was doing and they were
ending up in federal prisons and so um
that was it was a more self-preservation
it wasn't about hey let me join the
military after an act of War 9 11 or any
of that stuff let me just join the
military because if I don't I'm going to
end up dead
um and so I and I went to go join and
then the recruiter
she ran my background and she found out
that I had two warrants out for my
arrest which I didn't know I had a
warrant in New Jersey and I had a
warrant in New York I was I was
petrified because at this point I didn't
know what the warrants were for so uh at
the time and so I thought it was for the
stuff that I was doing and you know as
it related to the phones and uh got up
got ready to run out of the office and
she stopped me right before I got out
getting you know right before I crushed
it Across the Threshold and she said hey
what are you doing I said I'm getting
out of here she said uh you have a suit
I said no she asked me if I had a
college shirt and some nice pants I said
I'm sure I could find something and she
told me to come back tomorrow and I said
for what she snapped at me and said just
come back tomorrow okay and uh growing
up in the streets of the Bronx
especially when I was hustling I had to
learn how to read people and that would
later serve me well and when I got into
human intelligence and from her response
and reaction the way she had been for
the last hours in her office I was able
to read that she whatever it was that
she was going to do for me it was going
to be good I didn't know exactly what it
was going to be but I knew they would be
good and so I came back the next day and
she took me to both judges she had on
her dress uniform and took me to both
judges to judge in New Jersey uh judge
in New York Advocate on my behalf she
kind of used the uh the the uh 911 as a
way to get me in she said hey he's
trying to join the Navy after an act of
War 9 11 took place nine months earlier
and I think you should give him a shot
and because he can't join a military
warrants or record and
um the first judge expunged my record
and I just had to pay court fees at
court fines and the second judge who uh
he was uh his Courthouse the courthouse
was coincidentally blocks away from
Ground Zero he you know so there was a
lot of empathy there he expunged my
record and then that was kind of how and
then she punched the paperwork to sneak
me to the Navy and that's kind of how it
all happened so it was all about
self-preservation so when you get in do
you go straight to Seal training or you
go to the regular Navy first yeah go to
the regular Navy first I wasn't
qualified uh academically I didn't have
the ASVAB scores and I couldn't swim and
I was super skinny so um I went to uh
Naval Hospital Camp Pendleton first I
did a year there and uh I just I just as
soon as I got there I just trained hard
you know I didn't have a car so I run
three miles uphill to the pool jump in
the shallow end try to figure it out run
three miles back I got to ask about the
dummy's book which is like an s.a.t book
and I studied that book religiously and
then I uh I watched the buds two three
four documentary and saw a lot of guys
worked out and I built my workout plans
uh around what they did and within a
year of checking into the command I was
checking out and on my way to Seal
training so it was a year process
what was training like
buds it was it sucks it was uh it sucked
and uh uh being being uh uh
I couldn't get away with anything
because you know uh less than one
percent of Navy SEALs are
African-American and then when every
class that I had been in you know I'm
like one or one or one of one or one of
three African-Americans in the class and
uh and so I couldn't get away with
anything one two so I stood out like a
sore thumb uh and then on top of that
you know I I I the cold water had no
body fat so um when I'm in the ocean I'm
freezing is at the end of every two mile
time notion swim I mean the borderline
hypothermic or hypothermic so that
sucked and it's just a brutal it's a
brutal process man and it has to be
um uh because they're trying to uh uh
create Warriors who will be able to go
in any situation outnumbered outgun and
still get the job done and so it's
absolutely necessary and it has to be
tough I mean the attrition rate is
anywhere between 80 and 90 percent the
class I grad graduated was started with
two 270 29 of us finished and that's
just the way it is every class so um it
sucked it's so bad but it was necessary
I've talked to a lot of seals about this
what do you think about all the public
pressure to make it softer to basically
I hate it I I think it's all political
um uh for
um
diversity's sake I say that in air
quotes I think you know you know that's
you know that's a job where you have to
have uh
person in it that's qualified you know
what I mean and it's it's not a job
where you can water it down and to get
numbers in or to be the quota otherwise
you're going to create casualties
um I will say that the SEAL Teams buds
training and then the SEAL Teams that
was the first Community
um that I felt like I was a part of that
didn't care at all whether I was black
or white and they didn't care all they
cared about was can you do your job you
know can you perform and if you can't
perform you're out of here if you could
perform then you're you stay in and I I
hate the idea of of people trying to
have politicians and you know the
majority of people who are trying to you
know water it down change it are people
who had didn't serve or will have never
served uh not just in the military but
in Special Operations so it's easy to
armchair quarterback and say why aren't
there enough this group or that group in
there why ain't enough blacks and
they're laying enough women and this
then and how about you go through
training first and then you tell me why
well I think what many people don't
realize I was in the regular army and uh
Special Operations is even that on
steroids
um is the trust that a team needs right
and so to your point it's not only can
you do your job job you know in training
but I'm assuming when you're kicking in
the door and Iraq or Afghanistan you
need to know that the person next to you
can shoot straight can move can
communicate catch your back is gonna not
[__] run out of the building the
first time someone shoots back like all
these different things that trust and
and that confidence and competence that
comes with uh having people who've gone
through the training is a huge piece
like the psychological component is
really important 100 it's total buy-in
you know um I like like an example you
used was perfect when I go into it when
I was doing direct action missions the
downrange I won't mention the countries
out you know that I operated in
um but you know when I was doing da
missions and we went and I had to I was
appoint first man in a second man and I
knew if I was first man and the guy
behind me is going to cover my corner be
the second man and right behind me
covering down the section and I can't
see I didn't have to worry about is he
gonna after I go in is he gonna really
clear his corner or am I going to get
shot in the back by somebody who's
hiding in the corner I knew that he was
going to do what are you gonna do and
even even more more than that I knew
that when hoop hit the fan
like when things were out of control
that that dude was not going to quit in
that because it's not just about
the fear of of of of uh going in and
somebody running out because they're
scared of getting shot and it's more
about yo you've been you're half your
platoon has been shot up or the Birds
crashed or you've been on an OP for
freaking eight hours and it's 130
degrees out it was just supposed to be a
quick snatch and grab and you know that
each guy is still going to give 110 you
know that each guy is not even paying
attention to the fact that he might have
have been shot and bleed now I mean case
in point Lone Survivor that's a great
that's a great case study right there
you know that proves why we do what we
did why we do what we do because you
know those guys Marcus and and axel and
and Murph and those guys
they were in the middle of a storm and
they kept on fighting they weren't
firing fighting for themselves they kept
them fighting for the guy to their right
and they left outnumbered shot up you
know uh
guy died another guy died still going
still fighting for each other and and
that perseverance that that no quit
attitude in the face of ominous uh you
know
absolute distress death you name it you
can only get that out of our out of the
program that we there that we uh come
out of and so um so yeah man well I
think a big part of it too is uh you
can't recreate that scenario or or other
types of scenarios in training but you
sure can put people through a lot of
pain right and kind of test them
mentally and so how much of the training
did you feel was it was physical versus
mental
it's all mental in my opinion every guy
that shows up to training
physically has what it takes to to be
there make it otherwise you want to get
in you got to pass like a 500 yard swim
push-ups sit-ups pull up certain numbers
all out of stuff and you can't just pass
it you have to score what's called
competitive scores and then you got to
take a physical examination and the
psychological and then all the stuff so
every single person that shows up has
what it takes physically the question
now becomes who has what it takes
mentally all the instructors are doing
and this is what we did on the Special
Forces fox show and this is what I do
when I work with corporations and pro
athletes all we're doing is taking
physical tools to drive home
intellectual points we're using the
physical to challenge them mentally and
that's what it's about all at the end of
the day so for me my personal opinion
it's it's 90 mental 10 physical I mean
the the in the 10 physical I mean
they're just using that 10 to put to to
push that 90 within your within your
psyche and your brain so one of the
things uh I hear people who've never
served in the middle military before
never you know gone overseas or anything
like that they'll talk about fear and
how fear really is uh this thing that uh
obviously soldiers don't get scared
right obviously seals don't get scared
uh talk a little bit about fear whether
you ever were scared you know when
you're out in the field or operating on
missions and whether that was something
that could be debilitating or actually
something that you could use to your
advantage and kind of spur yourself into
action yeah I think fear is good fear is
a good thing
um because it keeps you from doing the
wrong thing in my opinion
um I my greatest fear when going on a
missions what it wasn't death I gave up
the I gave up the fear of death the
moment I raised my hand and said I'll
join the military and then even more so
when I freaking said I'm gonna go to
buzz and then even more so when I said
I'm going to be a frog man because I
knew that I could die at any moment and
you have to give up that fear of death
my greatest fear was doing something or
not doing something
that would lead to the serious injury or
death of my teammate that was my fear
and that fear was good because it it
really helped Focus me on doing the
right things you know as I said I was
like I was a human I was a medic but I
was also a human guy which stands for
human intelligence and so I I got to go
to different intelligence schools and I
had to learn how to run sources and do
all that cool stuff trading craft all
that cool stuff and that's kind of where
chameleon kind of came out of and um
and so I was building the intelligence
packages that would lead to us well that
would lead to us going on direct action
missions and so I had to really vet my
information with my sources and against
other information and double vetted and
check it and do because my fear was
getting a piece of information or maybe
I'm in a meeting with a source and I'm
not paying attention to all the telltale
signs is he lying to me is he just
trying to send me to a place where I go
into the me my team going to the
building then somebody Clacks off a bomb
and we're all dead I had to focus even
more so and that Focus came out of that
fear of leading my teammates into a
situation that that's going to kill them
right and so uh fear was good and it was
always good but again it was more so the
fear of doing something or not doing
something that would that would hurt or
lead to the death of my teammates and
that's something that you know when I'm
talking to uh uh entrepreneurs and and
CEOs and companies that's something that
I always preach I said you know utilize
that fear but don't utilize it in a
selfish way think about your employees
think about your subordinates you know
think about okay is this decision going
to be a decision that is not going to
just hurt me but it's going to hurt my
teammates and and return by hurting my
teammates hurt my bottom line one thing
I always try to tell leaders is that you
know uh it's the importance of taking a
genuine interest in your people because
if you take a genuine interest in them
not just see them as a stepping stone
stepping stone or sled dog or whatever
the tag we put on it
your people are going one not only gonna
they're gonna want to meet the standard
they want to they don't want to blow
past the standard they're going to want
to be willing to run through walls and
that was something I learned in the SEAL
Teams I had an OIC who just really took
a genuine interest in us and so we
wanted to perform beyond the standard
you know it wasn't about him prying into
our personal business it was about him
letting us know hey I care about you
what's going on how's your day how's
things back at the family what can I do
to support you what can I do to help
make your job easier and in doing all of
those things and actually caring about
us you know we wanted to work 10 times
harder and when you have that fear of
disappointing your subordinates or
disappointing your teammates it's going
to lead to you making the right
decisions so that that went and and
making the right decisions it's just
going to create this cycle of success
within your team within your
organization and so fear is good
when you think about the book and this
black box Thriller is kind of how uh
it's described it is based on your
experiences so it is not your story but
it is a story that is rooted in this
experience that you had talk a little
bit about human intelligence and what
does that really entail and then how
much of what people see on television or
in movies is real versus it's just
dramatized because it's entertaining but
it isn't part of the actual job yeah
yeah so um um I would say that black box
chameleon is a fictional extension of my
life you know it's it's it's uh and
transformed my Memoir I couldn't go into
the details about what I did and how I
did it uh and so this was my at my my
way chameleon was my way to be able to
to do it in a safe way where I'm totally
fictionalizing everything and creating
different programs and so on and so
forth but yeah human intelligence is uh
it's essentially it's using humans to
collect intelligence that's the easiest
way to explain it
um a good film comp would be one as a
matter of fact and I could say this one
in one of the courses that I went to
um the instructors uh played us scenes
from Spy games
um so uh if if anyone has seen Spy games
that's you know without me kind of
giving away information that I shouldn't
be giving away to the general public
that's a good cop for what we do you
know that's that's a good example of you
know finding somebody who and that's
part of the job part of the job is
finding somebody who has information or
can get access to information that you
need for a mission or uh maybe not even
a mission maybe just to get a uh uh an
idea of what's going on in the
environment that you'll be working in
right it's finding that person
befriending that person which is
building rapport with that person and
then at some point you know tasking that
person to do work for you
um to collect intelligence for you
because me as a as a big black dude from
the Bronx you know what I mean I
couldn't I couldn't walk down the street
of certain places in the Middle East or
even in uh even in some parts of Africa
because you know um because even though
I'm black like you know Africans can
kind of Snoop out an American easily for
the most part uh and and so we don't
have the ability to walk down the street
and get these jobs done
and so it takes these people these these
humans hence human intelligence to go
help collect that information uh and and
it's about training them and getting
them up to speed and knowing when to
pitch and and and when not to and and uh
and and reading them as well that's it's
a big part of it that's why I would say
that uh growing up in the Bronx really
helped prepare me for that job because
you have to learn how to know how to
read people especially when you're doing
the crazy stuff that I was doing uh you
have to learn how to read people on
order or else you're going to end up you
know talking to an undercover cop
instead of talking to you know a client
and ending up in prison uh and so um so
yeah that's essentially human it's it's
um it's uh using utilizing people
um to collect intelligence for you now
if you and I just were to sit down and
talk about uh you know kind of this
storyline I think that uh I could learn
a lot right somebody who's interested in
this stuff would pick up a lot of
details and information and kind of just
intellectually be stimulated but you
originally wrote it as a screen
screenplay and converted it into a book
which means that it's got to be
entertaining as well right yeah so talk
a little bit as to when you sit down to
write a fiction book versus the
non-fiction kind of memoir style it's
very different writing and so how did
you kind of get yourself into uh the
mindset and be prepared to actually
write the fiction uh component after
having such a successful non-fiction
book
yeah you know I think it was it wasn't
too hard for me because
um uh in part you know I I wrote a few a
few fiction screenplays before
um jumping into the fiction book so I
had the writing the non-fiction book to
help essentially give me the standard
right it helped give me uh my right and
left left limits as it relates to
writing a book because those writing
left limits are a lot wider when it
comes to a book than writing a
screenplay and then after writing my
first book that's when I wrote my first
screenplay which was actually chameleon
and and and those limits shrink
exponentially uh because you don't have
as much space and latitude to explain
and you know and give give a give a
sense of the world and and have the
characters give these long monologues
you don't have the space to do that in a
screenplay you have to get all of this
information out in such a such a small
uh encapsulated way and so the um
writing chameleon is a script and then
writing other screen plays that I worked
on fictional screenplays
you know it really that's what helped me
transition back into writing my book
because now I had these restrictions in
the in the fiction space as it related
to screenplay so now I wasn't able to
now expand that into a book
um so that's what I would say uh uh
helped me the most was having that
experience as a screen screenwriter and
writing those screenwriting books and
then and then now being able to go back
to that fiction length or standard like
that's you yeah going back to that
non-fiction standard that didn't
transform having that same Link in
chameleon but now taking all my fiction
experience from three act structure
character Arc uh you know the hero's
journey which you can't really do much
of in a non-fiction space because
there's just certain story lines and
non-fiction spaces that don't
what went into the Hero Journey or if
they do we would talk about 30 40 years
that you got to stretch into the arrows
during that's not the way the hero's
journey works and so um so yeah
screenwriting and then uh really helped
me tremendously talk about uh kind of
reviewing the book right so obviously
you can have tons of people who are
writers or editors and they can go and
they can read words and they can tell
you hey put a comma here don't put a
comma here you know you can use this
grammar or whatever but the substance of
the book is uh not very well known by
many people it's not like we're writing
about hey we went to the restaurant and
people are like well I've had that
experience right you're talking about
things that are very specific and so
you've got a friend who I think was a CI
agent who read it and was uh you know
helpful uh in getting you to convert it
from the screenplay into the book but
did you have other people whether
they're Navy Seals other teammates Etc
kind of read through and just hey give
me a gut check like this is realistic
and and make sense or did you kind of
just have to fly you know blind on that
part yeah no I did I you know Jack Carr
uh who uh he's been very successful with
uh the terminalist series which got
turned into to a TV show which I had the
pleasure of working on that TV show as
well he was one of the first he was the
first person that I sent the book to
um because you know he knows the
audience and he knows
um how to write in a way that's not so
heady that's not above the head of of of
you know the average person that didn't
doesn't have experience in the world
that we operate in and so he was the
first guy I sent it to him dude he I
mean his I mean his his quote is on the
cover of the book his his blurb after
reading the book is on the cover of the
book but you know he gave me some really
good feedback and and uh and thoroughly
enjoyed it and then
um Brad Thor who um you know he wasn't
in the world that I was in but uh he has
a lot of experience writing those type
of I mean he's been doing it for decades
and number one New York Times bestseller
multiple times over and so um you know
sending it to him and having him reading
and and give his input so that was he
was also very uh beneficial and Taylor
Moore as well you know he you know him
having worked in the agency and I had to
kind of lean on him a little bit more so
than the other guys because this is not
a Navy SEAL book you know what I mean
this is not a book about Navy Seals this
is a this is a book about a world that I
never operated in
um you know yes I did the human stuff
but I never operated on a CIA level
where I was you know uh they're doing
all that cool extra tier one type stuff
in the agency so I I really did have to
rely on those guys and uh and and it was
helpful for sure
talk about the business behind all of
this like you mentioned Jack Carr is a
good example right I don't know I've
lost count of how many books he's
written at this point uh but it just
seems like he keeps launching books
they're successful right he's obviously
got uh the Amazon uh TV series that you
mentioned he's just become you know
somebody who crossed over from the
military world into kind of uh
television media entertainment been very
successful you seem to be on a very
similar trajectory in terms of you've
got TV shows you've got movies and
screenplays and not books and and just
kind of you're hitting on all of these
different components how do you think
about the business is it just you're the
business is it more of like a publishing
type house like just talk to me a little
bit as to like when somebody says to you
like what are you building how do you
answer yeah I mean for me I'm building
it's a business it's all it's you know
it's it all falls under one umbrella
which is my eighth wonder which is
that's funny because it's the name of my
my um music company I kind of can't
retain that name for my production
company but it all falls under that you
know it's a storytelling business it's
uh uh and and our motto is to uh uh to
tell authentic stories and doing it in
an authentic way authentic and grounded
way whether that's through a book
whether that's through a TV show whether
that's and whether that TV show was
unscripted or scripted like Special
Forces Fox I mean I I I I I wasn't going
to sign on and do that show unless it
was going to be as authentic and real as
as uh as it was and that was one of the
and my no go go criteria is it related
to doing a show so
um um yeah man it's uh everything falls
under that one business and for me it's
all about how can one thing Elevate the
next thing and Elevate the next thing
and Elevate the next thing so
um so yeah yeah when you see the books
the TV shows and the movies what is your
favorite how do you actually decide if
you can only work on one project for the
rest of your life right like you get one
last one what's the evaluation criteria
how do you think about like what you
uniquely find enjoyment in
what is going to have the most impact
that's that's for me is is whether it's
a book TV Show filming what's going to
have the most impact because it was it
was story that changed the trajectory of
my life like that we had kind of breezed
through my story a little bit but
um the first film it began to change and
shift my mindset was bad boys uh because
that was a that was uh the first film
where I saw two African-Americans who
look like me they were cool but they
were playing Heroes and so I remember
being about 14 when that movie came out
and I was or 15 I can't remember exactly
and that's when I was just like holy
crap like I could be something other
than an athlete drug dealer or a rapper
uh and then a year later the rock came
out and that's was my first time I was
exposed to Navy Seals uh and so those
two films changed they they shifted my
mindset and changed the trajectory of my
life and so that's the power of story
and I meet so many people whether
they're in the teams or outside of other
avenues or other jobs and you ask them
hey why did you do what why did you
choose this career path and they'll tell
you oh I watched this movie and I read
this book or I listened to this podcast
and I was just super excited and I was
just super inspired and I was just like
that's why I want to do that's how I
discovered what I wanted to do in life
was through a story and so because I
understand the impact of story that's
why for me that's how I choose what I'm
going to do is it going to have an
impact and yes it is a business right so
a part of it is yes we do want to make
money right I'm not doing this for
charity but at the end of the day I want
what I'm doing to have some type of
social or cultural impact or impact on
on somebody on on a uh individual uh
level you know like like I mentioned
when we were offline you know the
underlying theme in in my book chameleon
is which doesn't come to the surface
until the end was this importance of
national you Unity there's so much
disunity in our nation and if we
continue down this divided path it's
going to ultimately lead to our
destruction and so you know I I I I I
wanted to intertwine that in the story
because I want that to impact people I
want people to wake up and be like ah
you know I do hate this person because
they're part of this political party or
but maybe I should just go have a
conversation maybe I should try and
build a relationship or maybe I should
just not attack that person because of
our political differences and you know I
always try to say you know Unity there's
a process to Unity it it starts with
conversation conversation leads to
understanding and understanding is what
ultimately leads to some form of unity
and and so you know again going back to
the answer it's all about what is going
to have the most impact especially in
the time period that I'm operating or
working in whether that's making a film
and that was one of the reasons why I
made my organ harvesting short film
which is now going to be a feature film
and is because I saw a need for it I was
working in the human trafficking space
volunteering with different non-profits
I saw that I I was unconscious of the
realities of human trafficking until I
got into that space and then I was just
like damn like I didn't know much about
this I'm sure a lot of other people
don't know a lot about this and so how
can I get more people engaged in this
fight against this Global issue called
human trafficking and I was like oh
let's make a film let's impact and so
now I shifted my focus from other things
that that I had already accomplished to
all right this is my focus because this
type of project is going to have a
bigger impact and I made that short film
and now that short film is going to be a
feature film and so it all comes back to
what is going to have the most impact in
the moment that's how I choose what I
work on
when you think back over the media and
entertainment work that you've done is
there one moment that you can point to
and say that's when I knew I could do
this
uh yeah I was working on six underground
with Michael Bay I was in Italy
um and it was a big star studded cast
with Ryan Reynolds and Corey Hawkins and
a bunch of other people and
um Michael Bay was like uh we were
shooting a scene and and he had me next
to him at the Monitor and he was like yo
um what do you think you know how would
you how would you he wasn't asking
because he needed an answer but he was
just you know asking to just kind of see
where my head visually is a Storyteller
was and he was like what would you think
how would you shoot this and uh I told
him and then he went and it was like all
right I'll try it out I'll try it out on
this take and he did it and uh it was it
was cool I don't know he ended up using
that that take in the in the final edit
but it was that was when I was like I
could do this you know because from a
storytelling standpoint it doesn't get
as it doesn't get that high the stakes
don't get that high as it does when
you're a director right writing a book
is not a lot of money on the line really
when you're writing a book for the most
part right uh you know acting in a movie
I mean you're getting paid your check
and you're getting told to perform a
certain way but the director is the one
that's in charge of everything and in
charge of you know millions of dollars
in some films hundreds of millions of
dollars and so to be able to be handed
you know the Reigns for a millisecond
and and uh and and accomplish something
um that was when I was like you know
what I could do this I could do this you
know it is uh it's incredible to hear uh
kind of your story and see the success
that you've had uh do you think that
there's going to be more seals and uh
people from the military who kind of
fall in these footsteps you mentioned
you know Jack and a few others that have
kind of started to do this there's
obviously the uh seal specifically
who've had certain experiences you
mentioned Martin Trail you know that
that either are able to turn their
stories into movies and books and and
that type of stuff but even just for the
person who you know yes they were in the
military but they didn't necessarily uh
have some experience that turns into a
specific book or a movie how do you kind
of see that transition becoming easier
or maybe it's still going to be hard
regardless of how much success you jack
or anybody else has I think it's always
going to be hard I mean the the book
film and TV but entertainment business
in general is a hard it's a tough nut to
crack
um even with people who are experienced
and and and they've been doing it for a
number of years you know it's uh you
know for it's a saying in Hollywood for
a movie to get made it takes a miracle
and so uh so it I think that it's it's
going to remain hard to get in you know
um but at the end of the day those who
really want it kind of like when it
comes to came to you know not just Seal
training but every other Special
Operations training even the military in
general right like like you gotta have
if you have a deep rooted emotional
reason as to why you want to do it
that's going to Anchor you and you're
going to keep holding out and then push
through and and eventually get through
but um yeah I don't see it ever being
easier at all yeah my last question for
you is the book is titled chameleon you
mentioned earlier like that's kind of
who you were what does that mean to you
right what what exactly is that in
someone one's life and how could they
maybe take the lessons that you've had
in your life and then become a chameleon
in theirs yeah I mean being a chameleon
just means being able to adapt being
able to adapt to any situation and uh
and I would say that that's also like
somewhat of a business lesson it's not a
business book per se but that's that
there is a business lesson that people
can take away from reading the book is
like how and when to adapt you know what
I mean uh uh uh and and and and when to
become what you need to become because
the reality is
we're all chameleons all the time you
know I'm not the same person I am with
my wife as I am with you I'm not the
same person I am with my wife as I am
with my kids I'm not the same person I
am with my kids as I am with my friends
like or you know I am with a boss who I
like or a boss who I don't like or
business like like we're always
chameleons all the time it's just we're
not conscious of it and so you know uh I
would just say to people that you know
that's uh that's kind of how it that's
how it all came to me that's what it
means to be a chameleon is to is to
really be focused on being what you need
to be uh in the moment or in this
situation to get the job done and uh
that's what I hope people are able to
take away from the book and even when we
get to there's a lot of interrogations
in the book right and and at the end of
the day that's what business
negotiations are sometimes it's like how
do you get this information out of a
person that you need to get out of the
person so that that way you can
negotiate a better deal and so even in
the writing of those interrogation
scenes I try to put some you know some
of those business negotiation beats and
uh uh edicts into those interrogations
so that people can be oh that's a good
idea maybe I'll I'll try that technique
maybe I'll try this when I'm in the
business room negotiating so uh that's
what I hope people get out of the book
it's one you know the importance of uh
of of political and not just political
but National unity in our nation into
hey we're all chameleons let's just
focus on being chameleons for the
greater good
I love that where can we send people to
find you on the internet or find the
book yeah so you can find me anywhere uh
on social media Instagram Twitter
Facebook uh LinkedIn Remy adelaki I got
a unique name so it's not the official
it's just Remy adeleke and uh the book
you can find a book of wherever books
are sold I did the audiobook read so if
your audiobook person audible iTunes
wherever if you're just a regular book
person like to read the printed copied
in Barnes Noble's Amazon wherever books
are sold it's nothing like having the
actual author do the audiobook but I
will tell you I'll leave you with one
funny joke
um or uh stories I was listening to uh
Ray dalio's got a a book that came out
and he reads like the first chapter or
two and it's like all right now I'm
gonna hand it off to this other person
and he like Hood wins you a little bit
right you're like he's got like a real
specific voice it's kind of like a raspy
voice and he's reading you're like okay
I gotta raise reading the book he wrote
whatever and then he hands it off and
you're like hey man where'd you go hey I
bet he sold a lot of books like that
because everybody listens to the first
chat
because I think now on Audible they
allow you to listen to the first chapter
uh so maybe that's why he did it who
knows
that's funny awesome Remy listen I
appreciate you taking the time to do
this I really enjoyed talking with you
and you've had this amazing career
um you know one thank you for uh for
serving our country and protecting
people here at home thank you for your
service as well yeah well I
um uh always think about uh military
veterans are always looking for what's
the next thing right you talked about
adaptability and and it's really uh
powerful that you kind of had an idea
coming out of the military what you
wanted to do and then saw an opportunity
and just capitalized on it and I think
that it is inspiring for a lot of other
veterans who say look you know maybe I
know what I want to do maybe I don't but
there is something that is possible I
don't just have to go be a defense
contractor or go and work in you know
security or whatever I can go do some of
these other things and so I just keep
doing you and I I really appreciate and
I think everyone else does as well uh
same thing I appreciate you brother and
thank you and keep crushing it and uh I
see your wife is coming out with a book
soon so uh so uh let me know you and her
can compete with each other
yeah well two different worlds I think
she said hers is non-fiction right yeah
non-fiction yeah yeah let me know how I
can help support her man and tell her
congratulations on that as well all
right I appreciate you yeah all right
brother